So if you now ralla from what is
Denmark
my lines
of course I don't know Dutch either so
I
played it once or something like that but let's take a
look and it
comes around
I mean so you can at least play it with
something now  C5 can be given a quality, let's
see,
he doesn't take it okay,
oh my God, I'm just an idiot, it
works a little bit,
yes, but I didn't do it either, okay, let's
go back,
yes, okay, of course,
potentially
strong pawns here, because he has strong pawns
there
Let's have a look here,
that's it, get the parts over here,
so
the opponents in
Dutch always play such strange moves against me and
then I'm Mattia, let's
see if it
works the other way around, probably not like that, um,
bring it, yeah, it
looks like
somehow
Yes, it looks strange, knight E6,
my hanging C4
if it really is hanging but I think so
for a
moment but now I can
get in here
and would really hang C4
take
bishop E4
can also take C4 or it looks strange
yes of course I have to be careful now
if he takes hi4
bishop just has it in oh
no that doesn't work at all yes then
that might even be quite good
or
play actively
so now the question is
can you take it
yes E7 hangs
first E6 games
he doesn't have a field anymore no not so
long he does
n't understand the position either he
actually has now I don't see a
field anymore
yes but I can still take it then
comes the four or what is
probably coming  then G4
so bishop G4 FG knight can
take check with it I go away
then still threatens powerfully on H2
so yes good that
okay I thought if a queen had
three I still have the move or
not
oh there would be a powerful check here now
on the four that will be expensive
yes I was probably completely
confused
with the honorary position yes I have no idea
what that was like